uh you executive produced the show uh is
it Bobby light is that Bobby I love you
per me a good show yeah it's crazy
because now like I feel like on if I go
to like a Hollywood unlock you guys post
a lot of clips from uh they buy a lot of
advertising what's the name of the
network who's network oh my god Zeus
network is lit they're killing it Jesus
they're killing it they lend me a shot
to let me know they they buy advertising
they do great and they pay on time so
that's so let me ask you that because
you guys will post like every show that
they have there's like a clip that goes
on holiday they pay for it so that is
paid advertising yeah we're paid media
we're not earned media well that's
double because I want people to realize
like Zeus network is killing it and
they're they're paying for everything
they're investing in their brand limio
doesn't he has agree he does a great job
of cultivating relationship he nurtures
a relationship with his talent he makes
them feel valuable he gives the back in
on top of what he pays so like he paid
me to Executive produce it he paid me so
there's front end pay there's back in
pay he pay me a host that he pays for
advertising I mean he really invests in
his brand and I'm sure he's reaping the
benefits because I certainly imagine two
million one million two million you know
subscribers at 5.99 you're killing him
it's crazy when you see something like a
blueface and Christian rock situation
that like obviously is very uh probably
good for numbers for Hollywood unlocks
because every other day there's some
going up but it's obviously very toxic a
toxic and it could end up being a tragic
situation I just feel like it's like
spiraling into a a place that like like
I saw the no jumper thing that happened
yesterday and I was just like [__] man
like it's there's been domestic violence
there's been a lot of wild [__] do you
ever feel like
we contribute to that yeah
I know you're going with that um let me
say that they are my next guest on my
show okay um episode two episode two
very different but also very similar but
also very different they didn't kick
[__] break [__] was none of that
um because when I went into that
interview I wanted to try to humanize
the madness because I see what we post
and there are times where I will call
limio and say okay I think we're it's
going a little too far like I'm not
doing this ad or we can do this because
but at the same time there's also a part
of the culture that wants that like
there is an audience that follows us
that likes that and that kind of [__]
has been missing from the entertainment
space for a while well Love and Hip-Hop
had to soften itself up once the George
Floyd sub happened because black lives
matter was and also like Jerry
Springer's gone so I feel like that's
kind of like low-key like and here's my
excuse and this is what I and people are
gonna say that's no excuse it is an
excuse
this is a black owned Network and if
we're going to profit off our pain or
profit off our struggle or our community
issues I'm more comfortable doing it
with people than Viacom than Viacom
because bet is owned by a white woman
right Jewish woman
um and people don't know that and I'm
not going to politic my answers around
that but I just feel like it's different
like lemio took this Talent Bobby Joslin
um Nelly none who are on mainstream
networks who were not getting paid what
they were due who are not getting you
know the money that that they should
have gotten on the back end Jocelyn
helped build Love and Hip-Hop I mean
Loving Hip Hop well when they got
Atlanta is when it really blew up oh for
sure no no no no no for sure right for
sure I and I know and there's no Shay de
Mona who gave us all an opportunity but
like Viacom did not pay us what we were
when I did Love and Hip Hop season one I
got a thousand per episode wow the
Thousand per episode so the episode I
threw a drink on Hazel E I got paid a
thousand dollars for it that killed me
in many ways because it it forced me
into a space that I did something I
regretted and I could not fix it because
they weren't even willing to help me fix
it there's a publicist over there I
think her name is I think it's Shelly I
can't think of her I can't think her
name but
Kelly her name is Kelly this woman who
didn't look like me did nothing to help
me fix your image or my image or nothing
no press no she did nothing to help she
lit and then tried to uh she tried to
blackball me from going to the VMA she
tried to do all types of [__] because
she wanted to flex her power when really
this was a show where a bunch of black
people were coming treated like Bottom
Feeders and given scraps to go and beat
each other up from for for for the fame
I never wanted Love and Hip-Hop for that
I used it as a marketing tool like this
is a stepping stone to get in front of
the world launch my brand like I don't
know what the [__] these [__] doing I
don't care about nice people like that I
don't want to be mixing anyway literally
if you saw me on set it was how much
more time okay we filming in five four
three do my thing and I was out I never
politicked with them I never hung out I
never want to be friends with these
people because it was never about that
for me and when I look at Zeus he's
taking Joslin these people are making
more money than they probably have ever
made in television and he's given them
ownership over the shows EP credit so I
give him his his props for that that but
I do sometimes look at the content go
this doesn't necessarily align with what
Jason Lee is about but it is in the
ecosystem of what Hollywood unlocked is
and that's where when you talk about I
appreciate you saying that where the
Jason Lee brand and the Hollywood
unlocked brand are two separate Brands
although I own Hollywood unlocked I'm
putting me out more so you see that my
core brand is focused on empowerment
entertainment and um and education so
through empowerment through my
Foundation entertainment through my
platforming shows and education through
my courses